[Music]
[Applause]
be sure to check out Chris hayne's new
NBA podcast alongside Mark Stein called
hashtag this league uncut
Chris Haynes back on the program TNT
sideline reporter Bleacher Report NBA
Insider we're working on Victor one by
yama's nickname here
what do you think about this one wait
wait why are you giving me that look
because I was thinking with myself
that's tough I thought you were going to
put me on the spot oh no no no no I
won't do that to you we'll run a field
by you how about
escargot
the escar goat
no no all right okay wait wait do you
love it
no oh no okay all right fair enough okay
the opposite good okay
um how about v dub
no okay all right
uh pretty do you have one I do have a
few okay I had VV instead of wee wee V
for Victor VV
um
can I give you a few others just to have
a little fun okay
well sectors that are Victor sector
because he plays so amazing sick sure
that's horrible Eiffel power
it's okay oh a convictor
the bonjour Bandit no no no this is a
bad idea real quick okay Victor scale
Like An Earthquake Victor scale not
Richter Scale that's terrible the
croissant over dripleted worse
huh
born up it's sweet no no no no no no the
lube machine no Mr bagget ball no no
it's not a basketball Mr Baggett do you
have like how about we can't call him
wemby
right
we gotta have a better name than wimby
right Chris I would agree I don't that
wimby just doesn't set the tone if
you're trying to be a fierce competitor
in this league I don't know that wimpy
is what you want to go with long term
well you got you know you got the Greek
Freak Like The Joker those are good
those are good nicknames sturdy names
yes sir powerful names wimby just
doesn't do it
um but again DP his nickname will also
depend on how well he fares in the NBA
you got to keep that in consideration
okay any chance that he is not a great
player in your opinion
great I think there's a good chance he's
not a great player I don't see him being
a bus I see him being a really good
player okay um I think his his ceiling
is great and that's what I think we want
to Monitor and see if he can get to that
level but also going to Greg Popovich
who has had success with Tim Duncan and
also David Robinson how much more of a
head start is he going to get by going
to a place like San Antonio as opposed
to if he had gone some other place
no for sure when you definitely got
somebody who who's been there before
knows how to handle a number one pick
bring him on
um gradually doesn't put too much on his
plate you know Tim Duncan came in from
day one and he was a force I don't think
we'll see that with wimiyama from day
one but look you know take somebody like
Kawhi Leonard who wasn't a number one
pick but he kind of went through like
the Popovich Collegiate School of
learning where a pop Over a four-year
span just gradually increased his load
and they just kept developing developing
him I can see them doing that with
Victor
um on this time around and he has the
right system you know the right system
he has the right probably the right area
code to be able to just withstand a lot
of the hoopla yeah that he would
experience if he went to a bigger Market
all right Chris Paul was going to end up
where
I say he's going to end up with the
Clippers
is this a trade with the Wizards
I think it would be a trade yes okay
how do you think I think it would evolve
Robert Covington in a deal with some
other pieces but that's that's what I
think is going to happen
whose decision was it to get rid of
Chris Paul in Phoenix
you must have saw Chris Paul's uh quotes
from yesterday huh uh look I think
ultimately it was it was the owner's
decision
and James Jones decision I mean I
you look I think anybody probably would
have made that trade you know bringing
on Bradley Bill
um the fact that Bradley Bill wanted to
go to Phoenix and he had that no trade
clause
uh under his belt you know he he held
all the cars he held all the cars and I
think with Miami pulled out
you know it was ultimately pretty much a
done deal from there now when you're
talking about Chris Paul what he had to
say about Isaiah Thomas I obviously I
think um Isaiah definitely has the ear
of that organization
um you know I reported back in February
that Isaiah will hold a prominent role
with the sons and um you know at that
time's denied it and so I you know I
left that tweet up you can still find
that tweet that tweet stays up there
stayed up there for a reason I took some
hits I was on the rotisserie out there
but you know it is what it is I stay by
my guns but uh yeah I I wasn't surprised
at all
um about Chris's comments and do you
think what kind of fit is that Chris
Paul with the Clippers
I think it's a very I think it's a very
good fit now DP the the I think that fit
is well
um with Kawhi Leonard Paul George
because they need somebody that's going
to be able to facilitate the offense get
them in their plays you know kind of
um run the system especially in the
playoffs when the playoffs become a half
court game be able to get guys into
their sets now the the problem is you
know if they bring Russell Westbrook
back how was that fit can Chris and Russ
coexist together I don't know I would be
concerned about that uh there these are
two bona fide future Hall of Famers but
I I don't know if it Bose well I don't
know what the rose would be is Russ
coming off the business Chris coming off
the bench well we know Russ is not
trying to come off the bench at this
stage of his career so that's the
dynamic to kind of watch out for I like
to fit with Chris Paul if he's the
primary guy but if you have plans to
bring Russell back
um then that's when I think things can
get problematic
Draymond Green vacationing with LeBron
in France means what
means they're really good friends DP
really good friends and um you know I
think that solidifies it but you know
obviously Draymond Green opted out of
his contract yesterday he's a free agent
unrestricted free agent but
there's no I don't think there's a
pathway at all really uh which will lead
him outside of the Bay Area I think he
resigns with the Golden State Warriors
I'm trying to think if I think if I
believe if he would even
take recruiting meetings or anything
from from any other teams I don't know
if we even get that far I know there's
some teams interested if Draymond is
genuinely interested but I just can't
see him leaving Golden State but I
wonder you bring him back maybe you give
him a three-year deal maybe he makes 30
million a year or something like that
um what do you do with Jordan pool
what awards believe that they can still
get it done together okay okay
listen that's how they feel
I don't know but I mean that's that's
how they feel that's that's all I can
don't shoot the messenger DP all right
uh Dame Lillard
um
I didn't know if Miami backed out of
Bradley Beal because are they still
setting their sights on Dame Lillard
they then put they didn't put
everything in a trade package that they
could have for Bradley Beal
um they believe like I believe the Miami
Heat feel like
There's Hope like there's people across
the league that believe this could be
the offices and DP excuse me for my dog
my dog is barking at somebody back there
I don't know if you can hear it but I
think um Dame I mean excuse me I think
the Miami Heat believe that this is the
off season that Dane could potentially
request out and that's all going to be
dependent on well I think a large factor
of that is going to be what the Portland
Trail Blazers decided to do with the
number three pick Damian Lillard has
made it clear he wants to play for a
contending team he wants that to be in
Portland he wants the Trailblazers to do
everything within their power to help
accelerate this roster increase the
talent and part of that would be the
number three pick being an attractive
asset to be able to bring on a veteran
Player Pro you know probably even a star
player if you package that pick with
someone like Anthony Simon so a lot is
going to be a lot is going to factor in
with our Portland handles the draft this
coming Thursday he's Chris Haynes TNT
sideline reporter his new NBA podcast
with Mark Stein called
this league uncut
the chances Zion Williamson has traded
before the draft
or what
I'm going to go
I'm gonna go 30 not traded before the
draft I'm not ruling out that he won't
be traded before next season starts but
before the draft
I would say 30 percent
I'm wondering
if you're New Orleans well they probably
if they could get out from underneath
this they might would Charlotte be
interested in Zion Williamson would that
be enough you'd have to match with
salaries I know that but to get the
number two pick would that be something
that both sides would be interested in
well the word is if those two were to
facilitate some type of a deal sure the
word is Charlotte would want Brandon
Ingram and not Zion Williams okay okay
so they're not getting out from
underneath this Zion situation
it doesn't seem like in that scenario
there is other scenarios that could play
out all right I saw a report on ESPN
that uh one of the reporters said that
somebody close to John Moran feels like
the league is out to get him that the
media is out to get him
what do you make of those comments
well VP has had a few incidents yeah on
on IG live
that have put him in this predicament
that he's in now
he has no one else to blame but himself
um
maybe he's I haven't spoken to them you
know I I'm pretty close with his dad I
haven't spoken to his dad
um in a few weeks
but you know in this situation right
there you know I don't know if he's
thinking about I don't know if he feels
like people are piling on but
you know I look at it he got 25 25 game
suspension and a lot of people believe
that that was too lenient that it should
have been more and so I My Hope for him
DP
is that he just uses his time to get his
mind right do whatever he needs to do to
get himself in a proper
mindset and you know and just the people
around him that he tightens that up and
has quality people around them that's
going to help him grow as a man and in
his career
um this is when you're when you're an
NBA star or on the cusp of being an NBA
superstar and you have mishaps like this
off the court
these are the type of headlines you tend
to see and it it's it gets magnified so
hopefully he he learned from this and
doesn't put himself in this situation
again I'll leave you with this I said
this first hour is anybody under more
pressure next season
I want you to guess who do you think in
the NBA who is under the most pressure
which player next player yeah I thought
you were going to go with Coach nope
you're under the most pressure it's
probably Kevin Durant yep that's who I
said yeah I was going to say Frank Vogel
you know as the coach I thought that's
where you might have been going but now
Kevin Durant I mean this is his
this is his third time I mean you can
arguably say OKC they had a a big three
uh but they were younger then but you
know his tenure with the warriors with
Steph and clay
then um Brooklyn with Kyrie and James
Harden now here in Phoenix with um
with Bill and Devin Booker
yeah the pressure is there considering
the history and the path that he the
path that he's gone down in the past
people are going to hold that against
them so he's definitely Under Pressure
to get it done by the way I don't know
what your reaction was when Patrick
Beverly and Carl Anthony towns were
speaking on their podcast any uh Carl
Anthony towns said that people look back
and say that Karl Anthony towns changed
the game
um
could you tell me
how he will be remembered as changing
the game you're the expert
well when he said that I took it as you
know
he's probably going to dominate these
next six years oh okay that six year
window was going to be oh oh oh oh so oh
my bad I I was I was looking at what he
had done and changing the game my bad
okay all right I'm trying to give the
brother
that that he feels he still has some
work to do okay okay all right all right
fair enough I could be wrong I could be
wrong okay all right you know I hey I I
wanted to help him out too I just I'm
curious Patrick Beverly didn't follow up
by saying how do you think that you're
going to change the game yeah but not to
okay all right fair enough uh say hello
to Mark Stein for me good luck with the
podcast always great to uh share time
with you appreciate you my brother thank
you that is Chris Haynes TNC sideline
reporter and he's got a new podcast and
you got two great insiders there Mark
Stein Chris Haynes it's called hashtag
this league uncut as they dish on the
biggest topics in the NBA
#this League uncut available where you
get your podcast there